and damn it's November 4
it had this idea of creating a zero-g
sequence for some time hyung said yeah
we're going to for real we're going to
get on the real plane we're going to
crash it and I thought this is never
going to happen
there's a real physical challenge into a
0g it was really developed for the
Apollo missions we inject the aircraft
into a knobby
young people you are waited
it's a real set built inside of real
planes that's actually really going to
go 25,000 foot up into zero gravity we
had to prepare as best we could but then
we don't quite know exactly what's going
to happen
he wanted to be wild and violent and
spontaneous for an audience they're just
things happening in real time
there's no edit it's they're good
[Music]
experience this historic stunt in
virtual reality at the Austin Convention
Center ballroom B remember zero Niner
Niner
[Music]
Oh
and
welcome to new world of God
I monster
please meet truther dominant
she look lame what she has been denied
[Music]
you